mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
der wald lebensquelle des menschen
und energielieferant ort der sehnsucht
und inspiration einst eine gegend voller
gefahr heute attraktives erholungsgebiet
der wald hat sich verändert wie die
gesellschaft doch damit schreitet auch
die zerstörung voran jeder baum zählt
das landesmuseum zürich zeit dem wald im
wandel eine kulturelle reise jetzt weil
kultur platz
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz ja was
wären wir menschen ohne den wald es gäbe
uns schlicht und ergreifend nicht die
bäume unsere sauerstoff lieferanten aber
die bäume sie lieber noch so vieles mehr
zum beispiel rohstoff für die kunst hier
sieht sich in einer holz arena des
basler künstlers klaus wittmann und
diese arena findet sich im innenhof des
schweizerischen landesmuseums in zürich
sie stellt ganz klar dem baum ins
zentrum und das tun wir heute auch in
unserer sendung
[Musik]
beim umbau der schweizer wald wächst
jahr für jahr um die fläche des
thunersees und er wurde nie zuvor mehr
umsorgt wie heute
[Musik]
95 prozent der schweizer bevölkerung
besucht und nutzt den wald ein
spitzenwert wie eine aktuelle umfrage
zeigt
doch auch zu viel liebe kann er drücken
die forstwirtin jeremy wilkes allem an
ist co-präsidentin der
arbeitsgemeinschaft für den wald und hat
zum thema wald erholung doktoriert
was sich geändert hat in den letzten
jahren ist dass die leute vermehrt den
wald als freizeit ablehne arena erleben
also vor 2000 können wir so ein bisschen
im schnitt machen vor 2000 waren eher zu
die passiven aktivitäten die die wichtig
waren wie wandern spazieren und
heutzutage nehmen einfach die sportliche
aktivitäten an bedeutung zu und das
führt natürlich zu unstimmigkeiten
zwischen den erholungs nutzenden aber
auch innerhalb der waldfunktionen
die waldfunktionen ein wunderwerk und
wir lernen erst dieses richtig zu
verstehen
des wald lebens spielt sich unterirdisch
ab in einer handvoll wald erde gibt es
mehr lebewesen als menschen auf der erde
bäume ändern nachts ihren durchmesser
und sie verfügen über ein internes
kommunikationssystem
wurzeln etwa senden informationen über
nährstoffe oder den feuchtigkeitsgehalt
der erde an die baumkrone ist es trocken
reduzieren die blätter die verdunstung
bäume kommunizieren mit anderen
artgenossen
selbst mit weit entfernten sie nutzen
dafür das unterirdische geflecht der
pilze
über dieses netzwerk versorgen sie auch
den eigenen nachwuchs gezielt mit
nährstoffen
das netzwerk spannt sich durch ganze
wälder die wissenschaft spricht deshalb
vom world wide web
dass wir heute den wald als
intelligenten organismus anerkennen
haben wir unter anderem susan zum markt
zu verdanken die kanadische
wissenschaftlerin erforscht seit 25
jahren das mit wide web
wir haben erforscht wie mutter mit den
nachkommen kommunizieren eben über
dieses netzwerk dieses wissen ist
essenziell wenn wir eingreifen etwa
bäume fällen oder wieder aufforsten hat
das konsequenzen wir beeinträchtigen
dieses komplexe system durch unser
handeln
dass sich die beziehung zu bäumen in der
bevölkerung verändert hat nicht zuletzt
mit einer neuen art der vermittlung zu
tun für den förster und bestseller autor
peter wohlleben sind bäume längst wesen
mit eigenleben wie diese uralte fichte
in einem schwedischen nationalpark
das noch bestehende sie mord und
wohlleben vermitteln neue
forschungsergebnisse mit emotionen für
jerry lee wilkes allem an eine
zeitgemäße form der kommunikation und
forstwissenschaftler die haben beide
auch die sind sie glaubhaft dass und die
arbeit auch in den bereichen auch
bestens auch dem alt in ihrer art und
weise und was sie auch geschafft haben
uns einfach mit der dritte ort mit den
leuten zu kommunizieren und ich denke
auch dass die gesellschaft in einer zeit
lebt wo man an diese an dieser
romantische betrachtung des waldes auch
glauben möchte und ich glaube das ist
doch sehr schön wenn wir wissen wer gibt
der kurs erwerben der kleinen farm hütet
und erweitert von mutter bäumen und
unterirdischen netzwerken wussten unsere
vorfahren noch nichts ihre exzessiven
blutungen brachten den wald im ganzen
alpenraum an den rand des kollapses vor
gut 150 jahren war der wald in der
schweiz auf die hälfte der waldfläche
von heute abgeholzt die folge
naturkatastrophen
erst mit dem schweizer wald gesetz das
zur wiederaufforstung verpflichtet
setzte eine langsame entspannung ein
[Musik]
im zürcherischen zielt opel kann der
wald heute wieder fast ungestört wachsen
ein glücksfall für michael brunner
buchautor fotograf illustrator seit der
kindheit sind bäume seien studienobjekt
wahre überlebenskünstler
wenn man sie lässt
spannendes jetzt dass da natürlich
persönlich alte boh mit sda wie die
fichte die rotana wirklich auf den
felsen oder wachsen und extrem
eigentliche konzert entwurzelt und schön
ist dass jeder mit ihm alleine wohl
wirklich zu ressourcen und was ich an
überläufer und dass sie von dort aus
hatte einfach optimaler erosionsschutz
bietet in zeiten des klimawandels
gewinnen intakt bewaldete flächen noch
an bedeutung
in seinem aktuellen buch zeigt michael
brunner auf wie zentral der wald auch
für einen stabilen wasserkreislauf ist
fallen die bäume schwindet das wasser
mit fatalen folgen
aber zu stark wurde dann versiegelt
eigentlich goethes und dann haben wir
eigentlich nur überirdisch so zäh
absolut
den grundwasserspiegel der geteilte
sinkt und das eine station tiefes kreis
fühlt dass aber der wald verschwindet
der schöne da hat mancher und
wahrscheinlich interessanter mal
zugeguckt und geschichte sind all die
kulturelle völker hochkultur sie wird
mit dem verschwinden von der weltbühne
verschwunden
die wissenschaft hat aufgezeigt dass wir
den wald zum überleben brauchen
doch zum einen hat die gesellschaft ein
noch nie dagewesenes bedürfnis nach
einem ausgleich zum alltag und
andererseits liegt der produktionswert
der forstwirtschaft bei einer milliarde
franken
hält der wald all diesen ansprüchen
stand
jeremy wilkes alemannisch zuversichtlich
sie absolviert derzeit eine
weiterbildung zur wald therapeutin die
neuen anforderungen der gesellschaft an
den wald bieten sogar eine möglichkeit
die wertschöpfung zu verlagern ja
forstleute wir sind bestens geeignet ja
den wald auch die gesellschaft so
unvermittelt und ich sehe dass wir
einfach das pendant aus quasi sehr viele
business modelle für die weltwirtschaft
entwickelt werden können wo auch dann
der waldeigentümer profitieren kann
der gesellschaftliche wandel spiegelt
sich in unserem umgang mit dem wald
derzeit ist es die individual
gesellschaft die ansprüche erhebt sie
muss eine balance finden damit das
wunder wiesen wald erhalten bleibt
[Musik]
eine große wald ausstellung im
landesmuseum und was kann mein cooler
master schönhammer dass sie mit dem
zwitscher gold was glänzt eigentlich
führen wollen wir sind da im sihlwald
dass sie wollten möglich von zürich und
da es komplett selber über lohn dass sie
20 jahre das heißt ein mensch griff der
mini und darum wirkt auf uns ganz
magischen zauberhaft das heißt auch die
größtmögliche diskrepanz zum ferdinand
hodler anerkennt können wir doch mal
darüber kollegen das bedeutet dann dass
der hotelrestaurants regula moser also
eigentlich ist ja am ferdinand hodlers
in holzfäller symbol für stärke und
widerstandskraft bietet allerdings auch
in andere bedeutet mir wenn zeige dass
der mensch die natur eingreift und
saison schließlich auch zur größte
betreut wird
[Musik]
ja holziger wertvolle ressourcen muss
man als letzter vom holz musikstück in
der schweiz setzt als pascal maier mit
blick auf geschichte wie ihr wertvolles
thomas holz holt sich immer ganz
wertvolle ressourcen sieht der
jungsteinzeit griff der mensch im wald
und braucht immer mehr holz durch
störfeuer römischen vitrinen trümmer
sind
buchholz ressourcenverschwendung hand
wird amphore brennen viel holz bucht für
ca und für den schiffsbau und die haben
es also geschafft praktisch die ganze
mittelmeer um ab sollte
[Musik]
der wald in der kunst und jetzt darum
spezielle et romantique regula moser die
hat dann der mensch der welt zeigt
während romantik also ich glaube dass
man sehr eindrücklich gesät ist das
romantiker ist er ideal als bild wo der
wald vom alpinen ruhm per se grund
studiert das bild vor dem ideale waren
macht sich natürlich auch die tourismus
gern zu eigennützig
von deiner bilder inspirieren und
gesetzlich schweizer so
und was ganz spannende ist dass die
gunst genau auf situation umgekehrt
verhalten wie der realität das heißt
meter stört der wahl die wir dem volk
vor der industrialisierung desto
überhöhte und idealer einfach gewalt und
die ist dann vor der romantik sie also
sich so dass man wirklich ab beobachtet
dass der wahl diese grund stands lang
reiste maxi ist also mehr oder weniger
nur staffage für biblische und mit
themen und ihnen ist der mann ja auch in
wald inne und hatten sich zu eigen
gemacht und ich habe da an renal das ist
toll morgen was ist das für das beispiel
zeige da die schweizer mal europa zins
wo einst betrachtung betrachterin mit in
wald nimmt ist wald innere mitnimmt dh
erz und quasi in wald ihnen genau dem
augenblick wo ein neues medium
fotografie und er von notz atelier und
setzt auch in unmittelbarer und
authentische zugang zum wald finde zur
natur finden und sich im wald beweger im
wald maler die sich besonders erlebnis
strampeln für die kunst
[Musik]
für martin reick auf ein ritual der
maler fährt stets mit dem velo zum
arbeitsplatz pinsel farben und leinwand
mit im gepäck volk auf's atelier der
wald
seit 15 jahren ist er bald sein einziges
sie
konsequent
[Musik]
im wald statt mehr redet dafür 20 metrum
dass wir sind ein ort wo man sich drehen
ja bewegen kann sich die landschaft ist
das anders rennwagens verhalten im
umgang aber im wald ist vieles anders
logisch der eigene logik oder und die
versuche im wald arzt einfach mini
vorstellung verwalters maler sondern vor
hängig wer tritt aus ärzte was ich sehen
uns
überraschen was alles passiert
für reukauf ist der wald kein
sehnsuchtsort sondern künstlerische
antrieb nach 15 jahren beobachtung und
auseinandersetzung hat sich sein blick
erweitert
ja ich glaube voraus
es bleibt wenig probleme was ich nicht
für erforderlich
kontrast
wir haben bilder manchen bildern
der wald in der kunst ein abbild der
jeweiligen zeit
renaissance maler albrecht altdorfer war
einer der ersten und damals wenigen die
den wald zum protagonisten machten
300 jahre später holt caspar david
friedrich den wald aus dem dunkeln
inszeniert ihn als romantischen
sehnsuchtsort belegte mit persönlicher
symbole
seit rund 50 jahren setzt die kunst mit
dem wald politische statements
joseph beuys les 1982 an der documenta
in kassel
7000 eichen pflanzen unter dem leitsatz
stadtverwaltung statt stadtverwaltung
1998 bäume als lebende skulpturen rund
um die fondation beyeler bei basel
nach dem riesenerfolg der
verpackungskünstler christo und
jeanne-claude gründet ernst beyeler die
stiftung kunst für den tropenwald
hier das spektakuläre spätwerk des
schweizer fotorealisten franz gertsch
fotografieren übersetzt in hyper
realistische gemälde der wald als
projektionsfläche auch für einen
verklärten blick
seid ihr im wald malt macht martin
reukauf in seinem atelier im ruster
keinen pinselstrich mehr dennoch bleibt
es von großer bedeutung
also eines ist für trainer lohse ich bin
ihr niemals plane und wenn ich bis ganz
lager hat man sieht sich selber wohne
ich mich vorbereiten ums malen oder
das wichtigste sich anmelden oder das
sind relativ simpel ist aber ein
wesentlicher bestandteil also im wald
was im wald passiert ist die 1
geschichte aber im lauterer block das
bild ein zeit und doch immer wieder
machen muss und wieder machen sagt oder
nicht einmal in vaduz
während der 15 jahre monothematischen
schaffens hat sich sein blick auf das
unerschöpfliche thema gewandelt
sag mal klassisch
naturalistischen irgendwann fiel bund
wurde viel impulsiver viel staat
irgendwann ist ein sehr
verstoß wurde also fast schon schwer
gefallen das hat man das exklusives jahr
und jetzt wird es wieder langsam
also luftiger freier und firma viel
transparenter und aus dem wald auf
unterschiedlichste art begangen
[Musik]
boh 40
das weiß ich noch nicht so gefühlt bin
sich einig auf die hälfte also das ist
ja es geht mir so viel wie im nachwort
und von deiner bilder volley
weit entfernt
[Musik]
und da ist es verständlich
genau das ist unser 23 immer total war
kann sie kaum glauben dass ich einfach
konsequent da wo das tennis rutschen da
hat man sich ob es müsse überlegt genau
und damit 19 jahrhundert die erst der
waldschützer die hand zum beispiel auch
zu 75 erst waldschutz gesetz
ausgearbeitet dass ich sehr nachhaltig
sie also fast revolutionär vertritt und
andré konsequenz ist als gründlich vom
schweizerischen nationalpark sei da hat
man unter 40 einen ebay und dass ich zu
der zeit in europa der erste
nationalpark sei was überhaupt
nach einer serie von bruno manser ja der
bonamassa ist ein radikaler aktivist
sich wegen höherer
gewalt gesetzt und verglühte
trachtenbund wird sagen eure chance
früher oft wird mit den forschen anders
beurteile aus man das damals gemacht hat
sieht voraus sicher vorausgesagt
[Musik]
darum kann pascal maier doch um diese zu
der regular mosaikkunst für den wald
genau mit als großformatiges werk von
franz gertsch der waldweg ganz harmlos
taiwan fiel ist der vermeintliche
unversehrtheit leitet sie das werk auch
als ästhetische appel und
dementsprechend auch als usa betroffen
machen mich macht eine riesa baum hinter
ihnen betroffenen sich
riesig daher ist dass ich das so
genannte zahl paarung aus den tropischen
regenwald angeblich die größte baum
überhaupt
tatsächlich die maßstäblichkeit nur
entrückt es ist eins zu eins narrisch
nur größere christa und es gibt neue
ganze schöne geschichte rund um den baum
nämlich lud der ureinwohner im
amazonasbecken lebte die geister von
wald und das was du als nächstes machen
aber ist dass twitter wie im meer und im
speziellen bedecken brüder grimm spielt
der wald ein ganzes zu und regierung
es war einmal ein kleines süßes mädchen
das hatte jedermann lieb so beginnt das
grimm märchen rotkäppchen
das kind wird zur kranken großmutter in
den wald geschickt vom bösen wolf
gefressen und zu guter letzt gerettet
im grimmschen wald lauert die gefahr
er ist verzaubert verhext verwunschen
groß und finster
heldinnen und helden überwinden ängste
wachsen über sich hinaus der märchenwald
ein ort des wandels
die brüder grimm waren zwar vertreter
der romantik doch die mündlich
überlieferten erzählungen die sie
sammelten stammten aus einer zeit in der
im wald wilde tiere leben räuber
ausgestoßene
fantasie und die wertschätzung der
tradition das war romantisch
die überarbeiteten märchen
veröffentlichten die
sprachwissenschaftler als erziehungsbuch
mädchen beispielsweise sollten zu
gehorsam fleiß sitzern kalt angehalten
werden wie die illustrationen ihres
bruders ludwig emil verdeutlichen diese
machten die sammlung erst erfolgreich
der wandel der gesellschaft und der
wandel des waldes spiegeln sich
bilderbuch haft in modernen werken des
nord süd verlags
des größten kinderbuchverlag ist der
schweiz
der wald er ist nahbarer geworden und
das wichtige ist es ist ein positiv
besetzter ort man muss sich ja auch die
lebenswirklichkeit der kinder
vorstellen die diese bilder bücher lesen
also es gibt den waldkindergarten es ist
der wald ist es ein schützenswerter ort
die man gerne besucht wo man dinge
erfährt wo man ganz viel lernen kann
natürlich auch der wald hat seinen
schrecken verloren
auch in wo er mich findet von kalter
levy
weil es sich zu hause um sichtbar fühlt
macht ein mädchen sich auf in richtung
wald jeder schritt wird leichter sie
kennt jeden baum und strauch es ist ein
vertrauter ort zu dem sie kommt und
sie geht von sicher aus dorthin wo sie
sich für sich hilfe erwartet eben im
wald
dass auch der wald hilfe braucht haben
eveline hasler und kathi band erstmals
vor 30 jahren vermittelt
aktueller denn je ist die geschichte
zweier brüder eben erst neu aufgelegt
worden
während der eine sich ganz achtsamen
durch den wald bewegt respektvoll mit
der natur umgeht trampelt der andere
durch den wald und schaut nicht zurück
was er da hinterlässt und da passiert
tatsächlich folgendes die natur schlägt
zurück
eine natur die durch und durch beseelt
ist die nacherzählte sage aus der
südschweiz erinnert frappant an mythen
und sagen indigener völker so haben
beispielsweise waldbäume tiere in
amazonien einen übernatürlichen wächter
fliegt der mensch keinen acht vollen
umgang erfolgt die strafe der schutz
geister
was ein einzelner gegen die
umweltzerstörung bewirken kann zeigt das
buch es werde bald das im august
erscheinen wird es ist die wahre
geschichte des inders gaddafi der als
bub seinen ersten baum pflanzte auf der
sandbank steht nun ein wald
etwas anzupflanzen und er hat es
trotzdem gemacht mit ganz viel
durchhaltevermögen es ist quasi eine
kleine vorbildfunktion auch für kinder
schon im bilderbuch alter was du bewegen
hat bewegen wollen geschichten heute wie
damals und obwohl nicht mehr in allem
zeitgemäß sind die märchen der brüder
grimm populär wie eh und je
grimms märchen sind ein kulturgut diese
geschichten von gut und böse
haben einfach auch ihre berechtigung
gerade in dem jungen bilderbuch alter
also ab vier jahren
wird das ganz stark wahrgenommen und
verstanden auch geschichten bieten stoff
für diskussion und reflexion und wenn
schon die jüngsten lernen sich keinen
bären aufbinden zu lassen leben wir
hoffentlich auch morgen noch
[Musik]
ja das ist herrlich rohstoff jetzt kurz
und was das zeug hält geschäftssituation
wald wie gott anwalt rigorosen die
situation ist global sich drastisch im
brasilianischen ozean gebiert
werbetrommeln und der drei fußballfelder
abgeholzt und weltweit sich diskurs bei
flender waldflächen also entschied man
sich so das ist ziemlich drastische
gesetzlich der schweiz pascal mal in der
schweiz gesetzlich besser aus meerane zu
einnahmen von der waldfläche um 2 22
prozent
aber trotzdem setzte der schweizer wald
hits zu stören brandes wird noch nicht
so groß wie das natürlich um im
amazonasgebiet war nicht optimal für die
täglichen spaziergang durch den wald
region basra meyer und die haben es
gehört der wald hat alles lief wie nötig
so zu sagen und genau das macht mein
kollege gadient festkultur wie instagram
einig nämlich bäume um einmal hallo und
herzlich willkommen zum praxistest von
abramowitsch methode marina abramovic
künstlerin zeit mit deiner karte
irgendwann stärker fürs leben sind
riesig und es geht eigentlich um
nächsten konzentration bis sie war
nämlich bis die selbstbeherrschung und
willenskraft
was interessant findet marina abramovic
selbst raum mit einem überblick und für
die große performance vorbereitet
schütten sie einen baum ihr herz aus
suchen sie sich einen baum der ihnen
sympathisch erscheint umarmen sie den
baum dann erzählen sie den baum was sie
bedrückt sie können dieses sturm tun
flüstern oder auch schreien das ist
allein jeder entscheidung legen sie den
fokus auf ein kontinuierliches loslassen
führen sie diese übung mindestens 15
minuten
durch
[Musik]
leichte baum bringt der abdruck coaching
das gesicht scheint es also passiert
muss also die sorge erzählen werden von
art immer
größer und immer tiefer und immer
persönlicher so aber was marina
abramovic gut kann mit der norweger ist
dass man sie zubereitet was ich
eigentlich die essenz von weber um was
geht's eigentlich und für das ja mal so
lukas baumann gar nicht so schnell
[Musik]
die ausstellung zum wald hier im
schweizerischen landesmuseum in zürich
dauert noch bis mitte juli und nächste
woche das sehe ich sie hoffentlich
wieder dann reisen wir nach losen und
erkunden das spannungsfeld zwischen
kunst und krieg und gleich jetzt geht es
hier weiter auf sf1 mit der sternstunde
philosophie und der frage was trans
seien wirklich bedeutet eine gute woche
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos